do you need to know how to code to work
in tech no hey everyone it's lucy here
hope you're all doing well in this video
i will be talking about roles in tech
that don't require writing any lines of
code
if you're new to this channel i'm a
solutions architect graduate based in
australia working at aws
and because i studied information
systems in university which is part of
business school
i don't have very strong coding skills
so during my time in university i was
still interested in tech companies but
was more looking for roles within
product management
business development sales marketing and
so on
and so in this video i'm going to be
going through five of these roles the
pros and cons of each
what to expect and what skills important
forward height for candidates in these
positions
let's get right into it
the product manager role is great for
someone who likes to have a big picture
vision and love seeing how everything
fits in together
you're ultimately responsible for the
product strategy and take ownership of
the product roadmap
you work a lot with engineers designers
and other people across the company to
turn product ideas into
reality you also work a lot with the
users of the product
figure out what their pain points are
and come up with improvements to delight
the customer
let's say you work for a tech company
and one of their products is an iphone
app
you'll need to make sure the app meets
customer needs while also aligning with
business objectives
when hiring product managers companies
look for people who have an
entrepreneurial spirit
great teamwork skills and of course an
interest in the product
and because product managers work with
engineers and other technical people all
the time
it does help to have a technical
background but it's not necessary since
you won't be the one actually writing up
the code or designing the layout of the
different screens
moving on to the pros and cons the
product manager role is very dynamic
with a broad range of responsibilities
so every day will look quite different
which is great for someone who likes
variety
the role involves a lot of strategic
planning and stakeholder management
which is a great way to develop your
soft skills if you ever want to go for a
leadership position later down the line
however as a product manager you won't
be involved in actually developing the
solution you come up with which can be a
downside if you're someone who wants to
be a bit more hands-on with building or
implementing the product
the second role is the lead development
representative or business development
representative
a lead development representative or ldr
for short is someone who generates leads
and new business opportunities for the
company
it's a role within the sales team and
they spend a lot of time reaching out to
potential customers through phone calls
emails social media and in-person events
it can be quite a rewarding role for
people who enjoy a fast-paced
environment and also being comfortable
with interacting with strangers and
handling rejection
let's say you work for a tech company
that focuses on creating products that
small businesses can use to track their
expenses
as an ldr your role will be to seek out
new users for the product by contacting
a wide range of small businesses and
explaining to them how the products can
help them
when hiring for ldrs companies look for
people who are very ambitious and have
strong communication skills
the sales team is usually the first
point of contact for new and potential
customers
so being able to represent the company
and make a good first impression is very
important
moving on to the pros and cons a lot of
roles within sales are commission based
meaning that there's high earning
potential which means that you're
incentivized to work hard and smart to
deliver results
another benefit of working in sales
especially if you enjoy being around
people
is that every day you'll be interacting
with new faces and building new
relationships
however since many sales roles are very
focused on hitting metrics and targets
there's added pressure and stress if
your performance is consistently lower
than the goal
so whilst this pressure might help
encourage some to keep pushing forward
others might feel disheartened and
stressed by it
[Music]
the third rule is the content designer
content writer or content strategist
different companies like to use
different role titles but essentially a
content designer's main role is to
create
update and review the content of a
user's journey
it's great for someone who's passionate
about storytelling and being concise and
meaningful with their words
if you click on the website of a large
tech company any text you see on the
different pages was probably written by
a content designer and updated regularly
when needed
their role is to make sure that every
word and sentence is being used
accurately and appropriately to convey a
company's mission
and the product's vision when hiring for
content designers companies look for
people who have strong writing and
content strategy skills and have a way
of creatively engaging users through
text
having a portfolio of previous articles
blogs and technical writing would also
be a great way to showcase the skills
that you can bring
next we have the ux or product designer
a ux designer's role is to improve the
interaction between users and products
they take a human first approach when it
comes to designing a product and focus
on the full experience of a user
when companies hire software developers
to create a product they'll be able to
create something that functions properly
and takes all the boxes
but it might not be the most visually
appealing or user friendly
and this is where ux designers come in i
used to think a ux designer was someone
who spends the time creating
graphics and illustrations but in
reality a ux designer develops user
flows
creates prototypes and wireframes and
conducts user testing
when hiring for ux designers companies
look for people who are not only good at
coding but also have great communication
skills and the ability to empathize with
the customer
experience with prototyping and
wireframing tools is preferred so if
this role sounds interesting to you
have a look into tools like sketch and
figma moving on to the pros and cons
one of the most rewarding parts of being
a ux designer is seeing your design
being used in a product that can
potentially reach millions of customers
for those who love being creative and
hands-on the role can be a great way for
you to continuously improve your design
skills
because you receive so much feedback
from users and people in your team
on the other hand though since ux
designers receive a lot of feedback from
everyone
it may take a while for design decisions
to be made because of technology and
budget constraints your designs might
not get implemented which
sometimes give you a bit disheartening
last but not least we have the customer
success manager
the customer success manager or csm for
short works with customers to make sure
they receive you the right support to
achieve their goals
they're responsible for the customer's
success and so they're the ones
proactively contacting clients to check
up on how they're doing
if you're somewhat good at relationship
management and you love helping
customers solve their problems then the
csm role is a great role to consider
tech companies hire csms to make sure
there's a strong customer satisfaction
and retention once customers have
started using the product
very similar to the lead development
representative role the csm spends a lot
of time talking with new people
so if you enjoy forming new
relationships you'll find the world
pretty interesting
unlike the ldi role these relationships
tend to be more ongoing as customers
continue to face new challenges and
priorities
however because the csm acts as an
enabler between the company the product
and its customers
they don't directly work on improving
existing products or services
and this can be seen as a downside for
some people
thanks so much for watching i hope you
got something out of it please give it a
like if you did
and subscribe for more tech career and
student advice
bye for now